what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be reacting to some
kevin samuels clips before i start do
not forget to subscribe
hit that notification bell and let me
know in the comments if you agree or
disagree with kevin samuels
okay we're going to
so single or not do you want to be
married absolutely
okay any children i do not have children
all right so were mom and dad married
they were all right so who's helping you
figure all this out um
you me
really you my dad my aunt
my grandma who do you guys think let me
know in the comments is the best person
to help you with relationships
okay are you in a serious relationship
with anyone
no not at the moment when was your last
serious relationship
um i want to say what are we in 21
last one was in like 2019
and it was short-lived what's your
longest relationship
like a year and a half why such short
relationships
um i'm an artist
are artists bad partners let me know in
the comments i'm excited
creatives yeah creative oh no i'm crazy
um i've been in uh pursuing
my uh entertainment career since i was
like fourth
or really like 13 years old so what do
you mean your entertainment career
and what i'm an artist i'm a singer
songwriter performer
um so that's your first love that's my
first love
so you don't have room for her you don't
have room for her
why do you say that
uh just based on your life you
so you're oh my god you're making me gag
why do you say that i don't have um
space for a husband i have felt like
that before but i think the older i get
the more i realize um
that i don't want to be married to my
career
yeah but do you have the skills to do
anything else
absolutely really where's that shirt
where's that been proven in your life
um i think it's been proven in the sense
that i've been a caretaker
i mean i've been pursuing music no to a
man see
if you're trying to interview to be a
wife i'm going to ask you what you
what's your what's your relationship
experience
and you don't have much that's true
i've had a lot of situationships not a
lot of relationships
so you're unqualified to be a wife damn
you think so just because you haven't
it's a job relationships well were you
raised to be a wife
i don't think i was technically raised
to be a wife
so any woman that says that i've been
focusing on my career
following my passion whatever whatever
is a woman that raises the red flag to
most men
you're number one in your world
i can see what i could see why that
would be see
sadly and i'm gonna say something this
may sting a little bit sadly far too
many artists
fail at becoming successful then they
think marriage is a backup
men are backup plans men are primary
option to deserve your
best absolutely can you honestly say
that can you honestly say that you have
given me uh
the men in your life your best i yes
okay absolutely so the last relationship
you were in
this the year and a half who ended it
actually it was both it was not freaking
mutual
i agree with that it's never mutual um
okay
first it was him then we got back
together
why do you end it
you're gonna get me um because
because i was very we were both very
young
um but i was very much focused
on my career at the time you said yeah
how long ago was this relationship
my most serious relationship this was
like you said a year and a half
yeah that was longer years ago right so
everything i said has been accurate yeah
but it's interesting how he doesn't
think that that's like a long
relationship but he thinks people should
be engaged in six months that doesn't
mean that
um that means it is what it is you're
unfit for what you want
i would i agree with you i agree with
you on that and that is why i have been
taking the time to really work on myself
on that side of my life because you're
right i haven't
thought of what got into it with whom
who are you working with
well i have been in therapy but not for
relationship
stuff specifically but i do feel like
are you still in therapy
i'm sorry are you still in therapy
absolutely
how long have you been in therapy um
i've been in well i haven't been in this
year
last year and the year before so about
two years i was in therapy beforehand
but you're not you said you're still in
therapy so you're not in therapy
well i had to take a break because of
insurance issues
that's not what you just said you said
you're still in therapy you're not
damn well why don't women answer his
questions
just ma'am it's just no ma'am no there's
no no ma'am no no no no no
no no words mean things
it's almost june and you said you're in
therapy implying that this still ongoing
it turns out you haven't been in here
all year
damn yeah so so you're not in therapy
you just want to
see yeah i'm concerned how casually
women lie
these days well i wasn't lying attention
intentionally it was not it was not
factual
you know you ain't been to therapy in
2021 so that means i'm not in therapy
girls do do this a lot like white lies
i know about that but so do guy people
lie that's that's what i've noticed in
life it's not really a man or a woman
thing
people lie no
i'm not playing these games this is
another part of the reason why women are
so unfit for relationships
y'all play slick and loose with words
words are used to express reality not
create reality
far too many women use words to create
reality you're sitting here trying to
play reality games in front of everybody
what man wants to deal with that
i have been in therapy for an extended
period of time
in 2021 i stopped i know that now
i know that now because i've had to peel
back the onion
but what i'm saying in a normal
interaction you would have given the
wrong
information to somebody my point is man
therapy or no the fitness to be inside
of a relationship
you need to be coming to the table to
bring something
women like you come and take stuff
what is a man going to get from you
outside of sex
well one thing that i've learned being
around a lot of men
is that um they don't always get
heard they're not always listened to um
and they're not always nurtured in the
way that women
naturally what was the question i asked
you
the question that you asked me is that
what i think because
kevin worked in sales he could see all
the sales tactics of like not
telling the truth about stuff given to
a man so i'm getting to that is the
nurturing
aspect and the being able to be
a listener and actually take what i'm
hearing
and apply it like i think that's
something that a lot of young women my
age where did you learn this skill
i learned this skill from i think um how
long
how long have you had this skill should
i say
um i think i've always kind of had that
skill like
lean forward leave for a little leave
for a little bit
lean forward uh-huh yeah
see if you had that skill to listen and
respond and apply your first boyfriend
the one who you would for a year and
some change wouldn't have said you were
too focused on your career
because i'm quite younger i know what
you said you've had this you said you
paid this
you said you've had this skill for a
while
i was a lot younger no no no no you guys
just saw what just happened right
i asked her how long have you been aware
of this and i and i asked you how long
ago i've had this for a while
that implies it was you should have had
it being and it didn't work then
yeah but that's the thing i learned
since then
absolutely that's not what you said this
is not what you said well i'm correcting
myself
since then after i've created
creating reality
no creating that's a reality stone
creating reality with words
no okay you let the comment section tell
you
i mean they can they can say that but
i'm telling you ma'am i'm telling you
man i'm telling you how
i'm telling you how i'm experienced i
don't understand why these women never
listen you went on to his show
well you don't have to agree with him
but then don't go on to his show
that you're trying to create reality
with words and i've asked you very
straightforward questions
and you've contradicted yourself
multiple times in your life
man listen listen i'm just reflecting
back what i'm getting from you i'm
mirroring you
and what you're getting is conflicted
confused
answers
i'm being very direct i know exactly why
i'm saying what i'm saying
you're creating reality just like you
create a reality that you're still in
therapy and you're not
just because you're in touch with a
therapist doesn't mean you're in therapy
okay and i'm going to say
that's a chaotic mind oh i absolutely
have a chaotic mind
okay and that's that and that means
you're unfit
for peace
you want peace no men want peace i just
agree that that's okay
so is that why he doesn't like creatives
because they have more chaotic minds
you can disagree but what does your men
want cooperation and peace
right absolutely but i don't think that
you can
um i don't think that disqualifies you
from being capable
from being capable of having peace or
creating a peaceful environment
because that's the point why doesn't she
ask if she like she's acting like she
knows it all then why are you on a show
like ask him what he thinks you can do
to help your situation go into therapy
because i know because
i'm a very solution oriented person
so
i just like i would prefer his shows to
talk more about like solutions for women
like her
yeah you don't think it's you yeah you
don't think you don't you don't
think that disqualifies you
from creating a peaceful environment
having a chaotic mind
absolutely not because there's something
called meditation
and what you're saying right right and
what you're saying is a man should
put all his ships and bet on you as a
wife that you got that ability
and this is what i asked in my comment
section the other day
like why men fear marriage and then like
most
replicated comment over and over and
over again was literally
we fear like marrying the wrong girl not
so much marriage in itself
well right now where i am in my life
maybe not
but
when you're gonna be ready that's a good
question i gave myself until my birthday
which is in october
really so you're not united she like
wants a pat on the back i swear
you're not in any kind of coaching or
self-improvement just watching youtube
i actually am getting coaching with who
i
mean how long how long business
marketing okay but that ain't got you to
do but see
creating reality we're talking about
relationships and you talk about
business
but but listen no no absolutely
not really
creating reality you cannot make this
[ __ ] up creating reality
look at her look at her eyebrows she's
so proud
listen listen it's like the micro
expression she said you gave yourself
until october
and you see how she's smiling but her
like eyes aren't smiling that's like
when you see a smile that's creepy
that's what it is it's because they're
smiling and their eyes aren't smiling
and you're not doing a mother flipping
thing about it you're not in therapy
you're in business marketing training or
coaching that's your priority
like i said your business your passion
is your business you're unfit
and you're not doing the damn thing
about it so you just think
by october it's gonna fix itself
wrong this is why you guys need to ask
thorough questions of women
and get them to answer let ask the
question three levels deep
man i i've only asked you direct
questions
are you doing anything today that's
improving your
interpersonal romantic relationship
skills
i believe what okay she should say no
the answer is no i am that's what i'm
trying to do what are you doing what are
you doing
nothing i think that me working on
myself as a
how are you working on how are you
working on yourself
when i'm developing a brand or a
business i'm actually having to ask
myself questions about who i
am and what i want from myself and what
i want you to do
those things all are gonna she doesn't
get it she doesn't get it you don't get
no it doesn't
and that's the sad part see this is this
is a i'm going to say something to me
stingray this is lazy
i disagree though i don't care if you
disagree you're out
that's fine i'm just saying you can
disagree but i will tell you
this is a lazy approach
this is what exactly listen
listen she does not know how to listen
you're not doing a mother flipping thing
about interpersonal relationships
and you're trying to say because i'm
getting some business coaching that
these are transferable skills
well that's the same thing when people
come through the door and have
conversation he said i'm doing great in
my life
in my professional life but i suck at my
personal life because those skills don't
map over but see
women have been allowed to be lazy
thinking well i'll just kill two birds
at one stone
i'll put my money into business coaching
and just through osmosis or
it'll all translate i'll be up i've
noticed that the most successful
people have very unsuccessful
relationships
point in case donald trump better wife
or a girlfriend because i'm learning
brand building and marketing
french toast out of here i don't have a
question damn
no did you know what i said i said did
you hear what i said
i did you said that it's not
transferable skills
so i understand um but i do have a
question
for you um so what do you
what would you recommend to some women
like me
who is willing to listen and to she's
not she literally has been talking over
him this whole time
maybe i don't know what to do because
even though my parents were married
most of the women in my family are not
or they have you know whatever situation
they have like they're always though
what's your question
what's your question the question is
what would you recommend
then like if i if i'm not supposed to be
doing business marketing or doing
self you know health things or personal
development what would i need to be
doing because i thought that
doing work on yourself is supposed to
make you a better person
no no you're doing work no
jesus christ jesus christ jesus christ h
christ
this is this is this is how far we've
gone this is why so many women think
because they go to school to get a
goddamn phd
that that makes them fit for a
relationship it doesn't that's true
i agree with you on that it doesn't give
me your stuff the same thing
she's doing the same thing so the first
thing you need is self-awareness to
recognize how
how bad off it is that's you don't think
it's as bad as it is for you
oh no i know i'm in the danger no no no
you know you're no no no
every ant every question i've asked you
you've
underestimated or downplayed or
overestimated
you've not been accurate in estimation
of anything tonight
i disagree okay
oh my she should watch it back because i
think she would
a lot of times people don't realize how
they come across until they literally
have to watch it back
um yeah my thoughts i agree with what
he's saying
um i feel a little attacked as a
creative woman
but you know it is what it is um let me
know in the comments would you date a
creative girl yes or no
and don't forget to subscribe and hit
the notification bell i'll talk to you
guys
next time